bonjour à tous sauf à mes voisins du
dessus ceux qui font la pub d'honneur
vpn cette vidéo est sponsorisé par noir
epn plus d'infos en fin d'épisode faut
que je vous dise un truc d'hommes à taux
forts et aussi non la terre n'est pas
plate mais je vais mettre tout le monde
d'accord est les paroles non plus en
réalité la terre est une vieille patates
et on sait grâce à la géodésie la
christina cordula des sciences de la
terre celle qui le dimanche est un troll
morphologie est et à ma grande
mais avant d'en arriver à cette patate
la terre pas christina j'oserais pas
notre bout de caillou qui flottent dans
l'espace est passé par plein de formes
différentes dans la tête des gens la
terre a notamment été rares disques le
single des lacs du connemara et oui nos
rages les globicéphales antiquités vous
auriez été la risée de tout le monde
trop lente car chez nos sorties grecque
la terre était une tortilla cerné par le
guacamole du fleuve océan et le tout
reposait sur diverses choses selon les
versions de l'eau de l'air comme dans un
jeu de air hockey ou de la piña colada
annonce assez ce qu'ils buvaient pendant
leurs recherches et par dessus notre
plat de résistance était couvert d'une
cloche le ciel avec les étoiles qui
défilent à la surface et une fois arrivé
en bout de course comment font-elles
pour revenir à leurs positions de départ
chaque jour bonnes questions à la nage
en empruntant le fleuve océans et pour
une fois je ferai pas blagues sur les
migrants quand soudain arrive à celui
qui va ruer dans les brancards de la
doxa le didier raoul tôt l'époque sauf
que crédible et compétent j'ai nommé
anaximandre de mulet miley pardon nous
sommes au sixième siècle avant
jésus-christ juste avant l'invention des
mini tel qu'on se donne un axe nous sort
entre la poire et le fromage voyez
l'univers la has un grand tourbillon est
en équilibre immobile au centre de
l'infini dans l'oeil du cyclone flop
notre bonne vieille terre comme ça elle
les vite dans le rien et elle ressemble
à un cylindre comme une colonne greg
coupet qui serait trois fois plus large
que hôte nous on bave nos deux sommets
sur la section plane sa mère dit comme
ça un tronçon de salami qui lévite mais
c'est une idée révolutionnaire ça devait
être un peu flippant pour les gens à
l'époque de se dire qui flottait en
équilibre au-dessus du vide et en
dessous du vide et sur les côtés mais
oui je pèse mes mots c'est une
révolution pour l'époque peut-être même
la toute première révolution
cosmologique à tel point que le
philosophe du xxème siècle karl popper
[Musique]
bonjour vous avez dit carl pope peur
désolé j'ai encore invoquer cette
éthiciens donc je disais ce brave carlo
a appelé cette idée l'une des idées les
plus audacieuses les plus
révolutionnaires les plus prodigieuses
de toute l'histoire de la pensée humaine
c'est ce que je me dis tous les matins
quand je décide de me lever bon ok tous
les midis on n'a même pas eu le temps de
lui dire pour son compte de formation
cpf
donc c'est une idée brillante tout ça
mais en plus ça permet de résoudre cette
histoire de la course des astres qui se
répètent sufit les étoiles passe sous la
terre pour regagner la ligne d'arrivée
et de départ du coup c'est déjà un
progrès mais c'est pas fini parce que
quelques temps plus tard un autre bouc
se ramène parménide lui se dit normes et
voyez puisqu'il s'y laisse ferrique et
qu'on vit dans un monde parfait et c'est
pas et l'ona qui me contredira là dessus
et bien deux facto la terre' l'est aussi
ce ferry qui cqfd ce que ferait donald
une nouvelle hypothèse c'est bien mignon
mais va falloir prouver tout ça m'a
fastoche nous dit aristote qui nous
montre sa lune la lune garder salle
pendant les éclipses l'ombre de la terre
sur notre satellite préféré est toujours
ronde ergo defacto mutatis mutandis
lorem ipsum la terre est une grosse
boule bonne grosse boule bien dur bon il
n'ya pas que ça autre preuve toujours en
regardant le ciel quand on change de
latitude si vous marchez un peu du nord
vers le sud où l' inverse mais
franchement qui aurait envie de faire
l'inversé je vous le demande eh bien
vous verrez pas les mêmes étoiles dans
le ciel ça c'est possible parce qu'on
marche sur une boule pas techniquement
une patate mais ne brûlons pas les
étapes bon à partir de là on sait que la
terre est ronde sauf ces plates east
d'épicuriens qui font la sourde oreille
et qui continuent de croire à ces
histoires de planètes tortillas mais
c'est eux qui tournait pas rond
si la terre est ronde c'est cool on peut
en déterminer le rayon et c'est là
qu'arrive eratosthène à cheval sur son
chameau mais pas le temps disait ici on
cause de la forme de la terre pas de sa
taille et pour ça je vous renvoie vers
l'excellente vidéo de je m'énerve pages
explique que je salue au passage
donc la terre est ronde bien perdre là
bas m'a bien ça depuis l'antiquité au
moyen âge on ne savait aussi personnes
affirmaient que la terre était plate ça
c'est une fête mais je vous laisse aller
voir cette vidéo là que j'ai faite chez
info ou mytho si ça vous intéresse et
aussi la géniale vidéo de l'histoire
nous dira où celle non moins génial de
défi 14 bon là il se passe plus grand
chose pendant un moment mais la fête
reprend à la fin du xviie siècle par une
série d'avancées théorique confirmée par
des observations on va se rendre compte
que la planète n'est pas une sphère
parfaite c'est plus un machin aplati un
ellipsoïde de révolution mais le débat
celui qui enflammera les scientifiques
de l'époque encore plus que faut-il
mettre ou pas de la crème fraîche dans
les pâtes carbo aussi de savoir si la
terre est aplati plutôt comme ça ou
plutôt comme ça c'est pas de la rigolade
les français les anglais se sont
affrontés à grands coups de source pour
les anglais mené par newton la terre et
aplatit au pôle il fait son malin avec
sa nouvelle théorie de la gravitation
universelle là entre deux tartes aux
pommes les anglais c'est l'ancienne
école de descartes qui pensent que la
terre est allongé au pôle est aplati à
l'équateur un peu comme un suppositoire
reste à mener des expériences pour
savoir qui a raison par chauvinisme
j'aurais été complètement types d'écarts
tu as we know aussi un des quartiers
celui qui a dit je doute par voilà
comment les génies de l'époque on tirer
cette affaire au clair difficile de
connaître la forme de ce sur quoi on est
assis quand on n'a pas le recul
nécessaire aujourd'hui il suffira
d'envoyer un texto au conducteur de la
tesla en orbite mais à l'époque et
c'était pas la même alors ils se sont
basés sur les méridiens céline
imaginaire qui relie les deux pôles
géographiques vous serez que le terme
générique pour ces lignes un méridien
comme parallèle c'est gratuit kull voilà
c'est cadeau fait toujours beau visage
donc nous méridien prenons un méridien
et profitons-en pour couper la terre en
deux ans suivant cette ligne imaginaire
avec notre couteau on peut diviser cette
section en 360 parties d'angle identique
qu'on va appeler des degrés ah oui on
fait ce qu'on veut on sait imaginaire
tout ça ce mort cela c'est un arc de
méridien si la terre était parfaitement
sphérique chaque longueur d'arc serait
égal si la terre est légèrement aplati à
l'équateur comme le pensent les mangeurs
de grenouilles l'arc près des pôles sera
plus court que celui près de l'équateur
et si au contraire elle et aplatit au
pôle comme l'affirment les rosbifs ce
sera l'inversé montmagny a plus qu'à
envoyer des stagiaires pour de mesurer
tout ça qasimi père et fils ont tracé
une ligne droite du nord au sud de la
france qui passe par dunkerque paris et
collioure reste plus qu'à mesurer la
distance entre ces trois villes plus
facile à dire qu'à faire a encore une
fois parce que c'était bien dans google
maps et les cartes de l'époque n'était
pas ultra fiable pas question de
dérouler un maître en couleur d'un bout
à l'autre de la france non plus alors
pour s'en sortir les savants de l'époque
on utilisait une vieille technique de
triangulation on avance en enchaînant
les triangles en prenant des points de
repère visible de loin comme des
clochers d'église c'est grâce aux jouets
de la trigonométrie on arrive à en
déduire à peu près la distance entre le
point de départ et le point d'arrivée on
compare ensuite la longueur de l'arc
pour un degré de méridien entre d'une
part paris dunkerque et d'autre part
paris collioure les cassini obtiennent
une distance plus petite au nord qu'au
sud conclusions des français la terre
serait donc bel et bien allongé vers les
pôles suppositoire un ballon de rugby 0
entre parenthèses je trouve ça
incroyable
ce genre de recherche crucial a eu lieu
sur notre territoire ou peut-être même
vous vous résidez pas sauf si vous êtes
david hallyday florent pagny sébastien
loeb ou arthur
mais faut croire que les anglais étaient
moins emballé que moi alors l'académie
royale française s'est dit qu'elle
allait refaire l'expérience en prenant
des points beaucoup plus distant sur le
globe on compare toujours deux degrés de
méridien là en laponie et l'autre pérou
à basses latitudes louis 15 ans voit
donc une expédition tout là-haut là-haut
mesurer la longueur de l'arc de méridien
du père noël et l'autre niveau de
l'équateur pour déguster des ceviche
d'alpagas vous la fait courte 1 les
expéditions à l'époque ce n'était pas
une sinécure lune aura duré un an
l'autre 8 avec des péripéties dignes
d'homère l'antique à le simpson quoique
y en a même un qui a été tué par la
chute d'une poutre et c'est qu'un
élément parmi tant d'autres bref l'arc
de la police situé à une latitude de 66
degrés nord est plus long que celui du
pérou sur l'équateur donc l'inversé de
ce qu'on avait trouvé en france voilà
qui assoit une bonne fois pour toutes la
victoire des rosbifs de newtonien pauvre
pauvre des cartes guides et cartes
hillmeyer
donc newton avait raison par ses savants
calculs il avait prédit que les manchots
en antarctique et les baleines en
arctique étaient 27 km plus proche du
centre de la terre que les pumas à
l'équateur bon dans les faits
aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur 21 km mais
en 300 ans a pas beaucoup bougé mais
alors pourquoi qu'elle ait aplati au
pôle me demandait de vous et bien parce
qu'elle tout mou galilée je vous
apprendre un truc incroyable
la terre fait un tour complet sur
elle-même en 24 heures bon en vrai c'est
plutôt 23h56 et 4,8 secondes mais on
s'en fout allez donc me faire un petit
tour dans un manège plus il tournera
vite et plus vous allez avoir
l'impression d'être expulsé vers
l'extérieur cette force qui vous bouter
hors de votre destrier en bois tels
jeanne d'arc les anglais c'est ce qu'on
appelle la force centrifuge décrite par
un petit copain newton huygens qui l'a
d'ailleurs bien inspirés pour cette
histoire de terre aplatit cette force-là
est bien plus forte à l'équateur qu'aux
pôles imaginez si vous vous tenez pile
poil sur le pôle nord vous aurez pas
bougé d'un poil pour rester au même
endroit pendant que la terre tourne si
en revanche vous voulez courir sur place
sur le graet hicules de l'équateur vous
devrez courait à 1675 km heure ça c'est
du tapis de course comme les cotterêts
plus loin de l' axe de rotation de la
terre que les pôles qui eux sont
littéralement dessus la force centrifuge
est la plus forte à l'équateur est nul
au pôle elle va étirer la planète aux
basses latitudes et la tasse et aux
hautes latitudes et ce qui est rigolo
c'est que cette force centrifuge
s'exerce dans le sens opposé à la
gravité du coup l'une va atténuer
l'autre et la pesanteur sera moins forte
à l'équateur qu'aux pôles mais pas
beaucoup moins forte de 0 3% seulement
ce qui contribue le à cette différence
de pesanteur c'est le rayon de la terre
plus vous êtes loin du centre de la
terre donc plus vous descendez vers
l'équateur moi vous subirez l'attraction
gravitationnelle de la terre et en plus
comme vous vous éloignez de l' axe de
rotation la force centrifuge augmente ce
qui réduit encore un peu le poids comme
on vient de le voir je parle bien du
point et pas de la masse moralité si
vous voulez perdre du poids rapidement
et sans effort suffit d'aller près de
l'équateur
et c'est d'ailleurs aussi pour ça qu'on
lance les fusées dans ces régions la
pesanteur y est moins forte et on
profite de la force centrifuge pour
donner de l'élan à nos bolides et oui
donc la gravité varie à la surface de la
terre ça c'est le truc à retenir les
plus attentifs en cours de physique se
souviendront peut-être qu'on considère à
l'accélération de la pesanteur comme
vale en 9 80 mètres par seconde carré
sauf qu'en fait non pas tout à fait
c'est en moyenne en vrai ça bouge entre
9 78 et 9 83 mètre par seconde carrés à
cause des raisons sus mentionnées
précédemment en outre
mais revoit nos scientifiques du xviie
s'ils ont pu se rendre compte que la
pesanteur variés à la surface de la
terre c'est grâce à une pendule oui une
pendule ils ont pris une pendule à
balancier parfaitement réglée à paris et
l'ont emporté en guyane pas sûr qu'elle
soit passée en bagage cabine seule
surprise là-bas la pendule accusés deux
minutes trente de retard chaque jour
comparé aux horloges de paris il faut
savoir que la période de six nations
d'un pendule dépend de la gravité
terrestre parce que c'est la gravité qui
ramène le pendule vers le bas dès qu'ils
s'écartent de la verticale plus la
gravité est forte plus le pendule et
ramener rapidement vers la verticale et
donc plus il oscillera rapidement bingo
la pesanteur n'est donc pas la même à
paris et en guyane et c'est bel et bien
lié au rayon de la terre c'est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler l'une des premières
mesures gravimétriques c'est-à-dire pour
déterminer la valeur de la gravité en un
certain point du globe on s'est empressé
lancer d'autres expéditions
scientifiques après sa pendule à la main
pour récolter plein de données
gravimétrique sur terre et en bout de
course pour dessiner cette splendide
patate dont je vous parle tout le temps
et que j'explique absolument jamais et
c'est là que ça devient intéressant oui
parce qu'avant c'était juste l'intro
ah ça y est on a mis les deux pieds dans
le domaine de la géodésie cette science
qui s'intéresse à la figure de la terre
c'est à dire sa forme et ses dimensions
elle peut même être considéré comme la
première forme de géographie moderne
quand je vous dis qu'on vient d'y
arriver bon c'est fort en bien sûr faut
pas me croire les cas signée avec leur
triangle là c'était déjà de la géodésie
la géodésie géométriques qui est utilisé
par les géographes pour faire des cartes
notamment pour votre gps parce que oui
il faut connaître la forme exacte de la
terre au pouvoir la cartographie mais il
ya une autre facette de la géodésie que
j'aime particulièrement non pas que la
géographie ce soit pas intéressant mais
bon on parle de science ici quand même
c'est la géodésie physique et notamment
la gravimétrie celles qui visent entre
autres à déterminer la gravité et qui
nous donne cette fameuse patate sous lsd
promis on finira par en parler pour
fêter ça j'ai qui cette splendide et
cartes géologiques qui nous montre
comment la gravité change selon
l'endroit où on est sur terre et non la
vidéo et pas du tout un prétexte pour m
acheter cette carte allez venez on va
regarder
or venez on va apprendre comment la lire
cette carte c'est pas directement la
gravité qui représentait mais les
anomalies gravimétrique en gros on
mesure la gravité à un endroit on
compare à une valeur théorique qu'on
devra avoir si la terre est un joli
ellipsoïde de révolution aplatit si on a
un champ de pesanteur supérieur à ce
qu'il faudrait notre anomalie est
positive est représentée en rouge et si
au contraire c'est inférieur anomalies
négative et c'est du bleu comme là vous
allez me dire mais c'est pas le rayon de
la terre qui varient comme ça là alors
non effectivement le rayon est un des
éléments qui va influencer la pesanteur
mais pas que ça dépend aussi de plein de
choses notamment l'altitude est très
intéressant la densité des roches sous
nos pieds si on est assis sur un
kilomètre de sel c'est léger d'abord on
aura les fesses irritées et ensuite la
gravité sera plus faible que si on était
assis sur une bonne grosse couche de
granit et voilà pourquoi les bretons
sont lourds donc ici on va corriger tous
les autres s'est fait sur la pesanteur
le rayon de la terre l'altitude tout ça
pour que ça ne dépend plus que de la
densité des roches du sous sol en rouge
c'est les endroits où les roches sont
plus denses donc c'est à dire la
pesanteur est plus forte que ce à quoi
on s'attend en théorie et en bleu là où
elles sont plus légères
et voilà comment on utilise la géodésie
physique pour scanner le sous sol oui je
suis en train de vous dire qu'on arrive
à déterminer quels genres de cailloux on
a sous nos pieds ou même s'il ya des
failles ou d'autres structures du genre
sans creuser en étudiant le champ de
pesanteur terrestre la pesanteur varie
aussi en fonction du temps ça dépend
notamment démarré le soleil comme la
lune vous exercez une attraction
gravitationnelle sur la terre qui va se
déformer un peu à leur passage et ça va
réduire le champ de gravité terrestre
mais ça dépend aussi de la fonte des
glaciers de la tectonique des plaques
tout ça d'ailleurs on voit bien les
dorsales océaniques et les fosses
océaniques sur cette carte c'est assez
cool non pas vous
eh ben
[Musique]
donc vous imaginez bien que la
gravimétrie peut s'utiliser dans plein
de domaines on peut s'en servir pour
voir ce cas sous les océans ou les
désert pour surveiller les volcans
actifs les nappes phréatiques les
glaciers les calottes polaires pour
étudier les dom de celle détectée les
cavités souterraines étudier la
structure d'une chaîne de montagne
certains gisements ou même des sites
archéologiques
c'est pas mal utilisé aussi par les
entreprises de prospection qui cherche
des ressources dans le sous sol pour
savoir où creuser oui ils vont pas
jusque rezé des trous au petit bonheur
la chance jusqu'à ce que le pétrole
jaillit ce ça marche pas comme ça et là
vous vous dites waouh mais comment
font-ils pour me dire lagré invités
se dote des machines super high tech et
bah non c'est avec des bidules qui
pendouille au bout d'un resort ont cédé
super bidule de très haute précision ou
9e chiffres après la virgule au moins
mais on n'est pas loin de nos guyana
avec leur horloge je vous la fait courte
selon l'intensité la pesanteur le bidule
va plus ou moins descendre et on va
pouvoir mesurer la longueur du ressort
c'est le principe de base des graviers m
sinon il ya un autre moyen que je trouve
particulièrement élégant on utilise des
satellites l'attitude d'un satellite va
être directement influencée par la
valeur de la pesanteur ce il survole une
chaîne de montagnes un peu costaude il
va être plus attirés par la terre et
donc descendre légèrement il suffit
ensuite de suivre le chemin tracé par ce
chauffard spatiale en état d'ébriété
pour savoir comment varie le champ de
pesanteur vous avez dit que cette classe
pour la petite histoire un bébé lecteur
loïs sais tu me regardes m'a appris
qu'il ya dans le ciel deux satellites
destinés à ces mesures qui s'appelle tom
et jerry parce qu'il se suivent en
permanence voilà c'était la belle
histoire du jour revenons enfin cette
belle patate qu'est le géoïde oui enfin
on en parle le géoïde c'est un concept
qui remonte à 1873 quand le
mathématicien allemand johann bénédicte
listings l'a sorti de son chapeau on
peut le définir comme une surface et
coûts potentiels de référence du champ
de pesanteur terrestre vous n'avez rien
compris ça tombe bien moi non plus en
gros on a transformé la terre en une
pâte est imaginaire la particularité de
cette patate c'est que c'est une surface
qui est horizontale partout on verra pas
comme ça c'est parce que justement
l'intensité de la gravité change c'est
ce qui explique les irrégularités sur
notre patate mais cette surface est
partout perpendiculaire à un fil à plomb
imaginez que vous voulez construire un
plancher bien horizontale partout sur la
terre vous finissez d'un fil à plomb qui
vous donne la verticale si la terre
était parfaite à la fin devrait obtenir
une sphère mais n'en déplaise à part
minime quand on fait pour de vrai on
obtient un patatoïde justement parce que
les masses rocheuses à l'intérieur de la
terre n'ont pas la même densité partout
et que les grumeaux les plus denses vont
dévier la direction du fil à plomb donc
celle de la verticale c'est
par convention on a placé le géoïde au
niveau de la mer le niveau moyen sans
tenir compte des vagues des marées des
courants tous ces trucs là donc le
géoïde va suivre globalement les océans
et se prolonger sous les continents mais
à quoi bon cette papattes m'interroge
êtes-vous et bien j'aime vos questions
le géoïde sert de référence notamment
pour les mesures de gravimétrie dont on
a parlé mais aussi pour tout ce qui peut
avoir à faire avec la pesanteur par
exemple pour les calculs de de
balistique ou de lancement de fusées ou
des satellites et les couleurs que vous
voyez sur cette patate que je vous
montre depuis le début c'est les écarts
du géoïde par rapport à la forme idéale
de la terre qu'on appelle ellipsoïde de
référence les deux ne s'écarte pas plus
d'une centaine de mètres au dessus ou en
dessous en rouge le géoïde fait une
bosse là où le sous sol est soudainement
plus dense par exemple sous une montagne
en bleu il passe au contraire en dessous
de l'élite solide de référence ça fait
un creux dont les reliefs sont
évidemment très exagéré en vrai la terre
est quand même vachement ellipsoïdales
on a assez des images d'elle de l'espace
pour le confirmer moralité la terre
n'est pas plate ce n'est pas non plus
une colonne tronqué une sphère parfaite
ni un kebab c'est un ellipsoïde de
révolution mais si on prend en compte
son champ de pesanteur et ses variations
alors c'est carrément une grosse patate
et la beauté de la chose c'est qu'on
peut aussi faire la géodésie sur
d'autres astres ici le géoïde de la lune
qui pour le coup est beaucoup plus
bosselé puisqu'il peut s'écarter de plus
de 700 m de l'élite solide de référence
et je trouve ces images magnifiques pour
finir je vous offre un petit cadeau
voici à quoi ressemblerait la terre si
elle arrêtait de tourner normalement
vous avez toutes les clés pour
comprendre pourquoi elle ressemble à ça
pourquoi les océans se concentrent vers
les pôles et pourquoi on pourrait faire
un petite rando de naïrobi à kuala
lumpur s'en sortir son tuba si vous
voulez vous essayer à expliquer ce qu'on
observe la section commentaires vous
attend
cette vidéo est réalisée en partenariat
non pas avec le lobby des pommes de
terre mais bien sûr avec norvez pnc pour
mon bing audio youtuber je suis
vachement fier regardez comment nord
fait p n a changé ma vie n'aurait pn
c'est un service de vpn qui vous
permettent de surfer sur internet en
toute sécurité je m'en sers tous les
jours pour consulter le solde de mes
comptes offshore pour suivre la
propagande du pays de mon choix et même
pour voyager à prix coûtant et oui c'est
le petit testing cerveau ne pouvait
choisir parmi plus de 5400 serveurs dont
60 pays regardez up jouera la carte et
en un clic je suis aruba up nous voici
en cure assauts hop je suis en palestine
quel dépaysement mes aïeux avec nos
revenus le monde et avant c'est rapide
c'est efficace ça marche sur téléphones
tablettes ordinateurs toutes les
principales plateformes même les
chaussures vous pouvez aussi utiliser
leurs solutions de tunneling vpn or lynx
pour regarder tous vos contenus préférés
sous un tunnel si les didier avait su ça
et ils ont même une protection anti
menaces contre le suivi intrusif les
logiciels et les publicités
malveillantes pour renforcer les ondes
telluriques positive et réaligné vos
chakras bon sens de la pousse et avoir
mes crises à lui mort vpn tu nous régale
car si la terre à la forme d'une patate
toi tu as la forme tout court
si vous avez été convaincu moi en tout
cas je me suis vachement convaincu
n'hésitez pas à profiter de mon offre
exclusive et limitée dans le temps grâce
à mon lien spécial cliquez donc en
description de la vidéo comme ça vous
êtes protégé pour surfer sur la mer
numérique depuis coin marieu ou même
varennes et puis vous soutenez la chaîne
en alimentant les fonds de pension et
des mois à accomplir mon rêve racheter
un yacht d'oligarques saisie par l'état
on fera une super top dessus
oups merci d'avoir suivi cette longue
vidéo très très longue vite et j'espère
qu'elle vous aurez appris quelques trucs
spéciale dédiée aux géographes un
spécial merci aussi à tous ceux qui
m'ont aidé à défricher le sujet sur
twitter cette vidéo c'est aussi la vôtre
et moult merci au type heures qui
soutiennent cette chaîne et qui me
permette de vivre de ma passion faire
des blagues nulles en prenant les
cailloux comme prétexte les cailloux
mais pas que d'ailleurs vous avez
peut-être remarqué que la chaîne se
diversifier un peu dans ces sujets
évidemment je continuerai à causer de
géologie parce que le sang mais
n'hésitez pas à me donner votre avis
jeffrey semblant que ça m'intéresse est
évidemment un immense merci à ma troupe
de relecteur qui m'empêchait de dire des
bêtises et qui m'ont proposé des supers
analogie pour expliquer des trucs pas
toujours facile à comprendre en fait ce
qu'on fait tout le boulot notamment un
grand merci à margaux et à jean-michel
courty qui a aussi sa chaîne youtube ne
pas hésitez pas à les voir c'est hyper
cool il ya plein de petites expériences
c'est très chouette bail
[Musique]
en
mais j'en suis chef
[Musique]
bah
mais
[Musique]
oups